The latest Disney and Pixar film to hit Disney+
is here just in time for summer — and it's
certainly made a splash.
The heartwarming animated feature "Luca,"
which arrived on Disney+ on June 18, is about
a young sea monster's journey of self-discovery.
Luca is a sheltered young goatfish herder.
When he meets the brave Alberto, he realizes
that sea monsters turn into humans on land
— and soon, he has a whole new world to
discover.
The fun continues when Luca and Alberto meet
the feisty human girl Giulia in her seaside
town of Portorosso, and the trio decide to
enter a triathlon together — all while Luca
and Alberto try to hide their true identities.
"Luca" is sure to be a hit with audiences
of all ages, thanks to its beautiful animation
and touching story.
While the plot of "Luca" has the same happy,
upbeat tone and structure characteristic of
Disney-Pixar movies, there are plenty of unique
aspects to "Luca" that make it a film unlike
any other.
Here's what happens at the end of "Luca,"
and what it means.
Spoilers ahead!
The final scenes of "Luca" have the potential
to leave viewers with a bunch of unanswered
questions.
In the film's last moments, Luca heads off
to join Giulia at her school, leaving Alberto
behind with Giulia's kind father Massimo.
Bittersweet ending, right?
It also leaves some loose ends: Will Luca
be accepted at his school in the human world?
What will become of Alberto?
Thankfully, the filmmakers address these concerns
-- though you have to stick around for the
end credits.
As the credits roll, sketches show that the
two boys are staying in touch, and they're
all enjoying their new lives.
The themes of friendship and acceptance also
have a big role to play in the ending.
Though Luca, Alberto, and Giulia have their
ups and downs throughout the film, they ultimately
prove to be genuine friends who care about
and support each other for who they are.
This is especially evident when Giulia realizes
that Luca and Alberto are sea monsters.
She's a bit surprised at first, but quickly
accepts their true nature and concerns herself
with making sure they stay safe.
Since Giulia is a bit of an outcast herself,
it's especially touching to see how easy it
is for her to accept her friends, knowing
that she isn't always so readily accepted.
The close and quick bond that Luca and Alberto
share is even more special when you realize
it was inspired by "Luca" director Enrico
Casarosa's real childhood.
He told Disney News:
"My best friend Alberto was a bit of a troublemaker,
[while] I was very timid and had a bit of
a sheltered life — we couldn't have been
more different.
[...] Alberto pushed me out of my comfort
zone, and pushed me off many cliffs, metaphorically
and not.
I probably would not be here if I didn't learn
to chase my dreams from him."
That thread runs throughout the movie.
"Luca" constantly reminds us to be proud of
who we are and accept others as they are as
well.
None of the friends in "Luca" try to change
one another — instead, they encourage each
other to be themselves, as good friends should.
A short scene with Massimo is another great
example of acceptance.
When he catches Alberto staring at his missing
arm, he jokes that a sea monster ate it before
explaining that it's simply how he came into
the world.
The topic isn't brought up again, and the
moment serves as a reminder that someone's
differences aren't the most important parts
of them.
Instead, Massimo's kindness, fishing skills,
and love for his daughter are the focus of
his character.
Andrea Warren, the producer of "Luca," expanded
on the film's theme of acceptance.
She told Disney News:
"We always liked the idea that the metaphor
of being a sea monster can apply to so many
different things.
There is a theme of openness, showing oneself
and self-acceptance, as well as community
acceptance.
"
"And I hope that really, yeah, makes us think
about the friendships that have helped us
find ourselves."
The ending of "Luca" shows how these friendships
forged during childhood -- sometimes even
over just one fateful summer -- have the power
to define us long after.
Thanks to Giulia's acceptance of him and Alberto's
constant urging to step outside his comfort
zone, Luca learns to embrace all the opportunities
life presents him.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.